Before we get on with Pastry Week,
I wanted to say how this show
has inspired me to bake for myself.
-Look at that.
-That's incredible.
Oh, it's nothing,
it's just a beautifully decorated,
mouth-wateringly moist fruit cake.
-So good. Looks like one of Prue's cakes.
-Thanks.
Hi. Do us a favour.
I'm looking for Prue's cake,
it's a beautifully decorated,
mouth-wateringly moist fruit cake.
No, no, erm, not seen
anything like that at all, not at all.
-Shall we crack on with the show?
-Yeah.
[both] Welcome
to The Great British Baking Show.
Hang on. There's Prue's cake.
-[Alison] This time…
-I've got cramp in my hands.
…the bakers face Pastry Week…
I'm nervous.
-…and double jeopardy.
-Two people are going home this week.
-I know.
-[Alison] They'll need to keep their cool…
-Oh, sugar.
-…with a steamy signature.
[Rowan] Oh, no.
-[Alison] Avoid a faux pas…
-[Tasha] That's not done.
[Alison] …while creating
a French classic.
I know what dauphinoise is.
What's the other word?
[sputters] Pfivier.
[Alison] And demonstrate
pie-making artistry.
[Saku] Ah!
[Alison] So they're not
among the two bakers…
Bit of a plumbing issue happening.
…who'll be leaving the competition.
Then we lift.
Oh, look, it's just split. It's broke.
-[Alison] Oh, God.
-Oh, no, what do I do?
[opening theme music playing]
[quacking]
[Nicky] We'll let you go.
Shall I lead the way?
[Nicky] I actually like pastry.
I find it quite therapeutic.
I love walking in.
-Do you?
-I do.
I never feel confident about anything
in my life and pastry's no exception.
So I'm just gonna roll with it
as I do every week.
[Matty] There's a lot
that can go wrong with pastry.
It will be interesting,
especially with two people going home.
[Cristy] I would love to,
like, blow their minds,
and get Star Baker would be a dream.
I don't know if it'll happen.
Bakers, you have made it to Pastry Week,
which means you lot are the upper crust.
[Noel] Now,
for your signature challenge,
the judges would love you to make
12 individual savoury picnic pies.
The fillings and flavours
are entirely your choice,
but your pies must be made
from hot water crust pastry,
and be attractive
and tempting to eat just like me.
[all laugh]
There's plenty of hot water,
so don't worry about that.
Even though someone here
had a 90-minute shower this morning.
Paul!
You have two hours.
Which is what Paul says
when he gets in the shower.
[all laughing]
-[Alison] On your marks…
-Get set…
Bake.
I know that I need
to get off to a rapid start.
This is the hot water crust pastry.
Hot water crust pastry
is traditionally made with lard.
Good for the hips, lard.
The other element is butter
and that brings flavour.
[Prue] You make it by pouring
almost boiling water
and melted fat into the flour.
I'm hot potato-ing right now. [laughs]
[Dan] This is my onion and spring onions.
Gotta put stuff inside that's A,
gonna be moist to the mouth,
and B, gonna carry
a lot of punchy flavours.
Oh, I love a sausage.
[Paul] The last thing is you want
a beautiful bit of crimping on the lid,
which seals in
whatever the bakers are gonna put inside.
[Prue] You need to
drop the lid into the pie.
The lid gets trapped in there
and it won't rise up and fall off.
[Paul] As long as it's consistent
and seals the lid to the side,
that's good.
No pressure.
-[Paul] Morning, Star Baker.
-[laughs] Morning.
-Hello, Matty.
-Hello, morning.
So, Matty, tell us
about your hot water crust little pies.
So, it's got ricotta and feta,
er, bit of garlic, some…
-Spanakopita?
-I'm glad you said it.
I couldn't… I can never pronounce it.
-[laughs]
-Pronounce what?
-Don't be cruel, Paul.
-Span-a-di-kopa-da?
-What?
-[all laughing]
[Prue] No, that went too quick.
[Noel] Matty's take on Greek spanakopita
will be filled with spinach,
soft cheeses, red peppers and herbs.
-[Paul] Good luck.
-[Prue] Sounds lovely.
I feel like this is your week.
-It's your week.
-You don't want to fall off your throne.
-No, absolutely not. Yeah.
-Yeah. You don't. That would hurt.
Looking good.
[Noel] And Matty's not the only baker
uniting a continental filling
with this quintessentially British pastry.
So this is my potato dauphinoise.
Dauphinoise is a bit classy,
a bit elegant, it's a bit like myself.
That I think I am. [laughs]
I'll bake that for a good half an hour
so it gets crispy with all the cheese.
[Alison] Dana's creamy dauphinoise
will sandwich fried onions
and melted Comté cheese
sealed in rosemary-infused pastry.
A recipe with echoes
a popular French bake.
-Sounds like a pithivier.
-What's that?
[all laughing]
-Interesting.
-Never mind.
Have you tested it?
I have and it has worked.
In the time?
I'm like, ten seconds
taking it out of the oven. [laughs]
[Noel] While Dana needs to accommodate
the baking and cooling
of her dauphinoise filling…
[Josh] So we've got sausage meat
and some strong cheese.
[Alison] …Josh and Tasha…
This is not pleasant. [chuckles]
…are making a traditional raw pork filling
that'll cook
while the rest of the pie bakes.
These are the same filling
as my Christmas stuffing.
[Noel] Tasha's pies
will get their Christmassy flavour
from the chopped sage in the sausage
and nutmeg in the pastry.
The double Star Baker
will be hoping to make it a hat-trick
after being unable
to complete Chocolate Week.
I felt weird not being here.
-[Noel] Did you?
-Yeah, had bad FOMO.
I bet you couldn't relax,
thinking, "What are they up to now?"
I know, it's weird.
It was like, erm, Stockholm syndrome?
[laughing] It's exactly that,
Stockholm syndrome.
At the end of the series, if you win,
you will get kidnapped by Paul.
He'll lock you in his basement.
But you'll like it, so it'll be fine.
[laughs]
[Alison] And while pork
is a popular choice…
These are Cumberland.
From a very reputable shop as well.
[Dan] How hot are these chillis?
[Alison] …two bakers are planning
to spice things up.
[Dan] Chuck it all in.
I made these for my kids
when they were young,
to go into their lunchboxes.
Not so much spice for me.
But I hope it will be good enough for you.
Yeah.
[Noel] Saku is making a milder version
of her Sri Lankan spiced tuna pies
which will see a spicy potato and tuna
filling surround a whole quail's egg.
Have you worked with, er,
hot water crust pastry before?
-Yes, when I was practising. [laughs]
-[all laughing]
-Was that the first time?
-Before that?
-Yes.
-[Paul] Never.
Crimping on the top?
-Crimpling?
-[all] Crimping.
-Crimpling.
-[Paul] Crimping.
But don't know how,
er, beautiful it will be.
-Good luck.
-[Prue] Good luck.
-Thank you.
-[Saku] Thank you.
Bakers, unbelievably,
you are halfway through already.
Oh, God.
I looked at my watch
and there was nothing there.
-[both laughing]
-I literally went…
That's 'cause I stole it.
Someone's stole it off me.
[both laugh]
[Noel] With fillings made, attention turns
to the lining in the pie tins.
I'm eye-balling the pastry thickness.
[Alison] Too thin
and they could split in the oven,
but going too thick also carries risk.
Hot water pastry, it's a bit thick,
it can be a bit stodgy, can't it?
[Alison] Dan's added turmeric
and cumin to his pastry
to augment a lamb keema filling
flavoured with his homemade spice mix.
[Noel] Quite excited about this.
Fingers crossed, it's greasy.
A bit gre… [laughs]
Not gonna say that to them, are you?
-No, I'm-- No.
-A little bit greasy.
-It's not that good.
-I don't mind a little bit of grease.
-I don't either.
-[laughing] Good luck.
-Nice one.
-Greasy Dan.
[Tasha] Aw,
I just forgot to put the mustard in.
We're off to a really good start.
[Noel] Filling also
needs to be tackled with care.
I am just filling up
to sort of around this mark here.
[Noel] Too little, the pies
will form an air pocket.
[Saku] Egg.
[Noel] Too much, the filling
could ooze out during baking.
They look good.
I want to make sure I've got them in.
Gonna take about 40 minutes or so.
[Alison] But Nicky
is nowhere near ready to bake.
It's cooked the egg.
I don't know whether to do it again.
[Alison] Her hot water mix
has scrambled the egg
she added to enrich her first dough.
I'd rather just start again and just,
erm, be done with it.
It's fine, it's fine, we've got this.
[Alison] Nicky's blending sausage,
ham and saucisson
with five different cheeses
including cheddar and Reblochon
packed into a classic pie tin.
[Prue] I love that shape.
-[Paul] It's old-school.
-[Prue] It's lovely.
-Just like me. [laughs]
-[chuckles] And me.
Have you practised this?
I've practised.
I've got pies coming out the front door.
-Been selling them?
-[Nicky] Yeah.
-[Alison and Prue laugh]
-Oh. It's too many pies.
[Paul] We'll leave you to it.
Sounds great.
-[Prue] Good luck.
-Fingers crossed.
Gotta get these in the oven toot sweet.
[Noel] While Nicky lines her tins…
-Pop lids on, bang 'em in the oven.
-…everyone else has moved on to the lids.
Easy as pie. I'm here all week.
[Noel] Two bakers are planning something
that requires a more refined touch.
This is the latticing of the pie top.
Providing the execution is good,
it can make the world of difference.
[Cristy] It is fiddly.
I've just gotta relax
'cause I feel so stressed.
I just don't wanna let myself down.
[Alison] Cristy's lattice lids
will conceal a filling of cream,
leek and garlic mushroom.
This should be such a good flavour.
You struggled a little
last week with flavour.
-We were complaining there wasn't enough.
-Yeah.
[Prue] It's amazing
how much garlic mushrooms can take.
-That's good.
-Good luck. Thank you.
-[Cristy] Okay.
-[Alison] Good luck.
To hold the fillings inside…
Hopefully it will be all right.
I learned the right word today, crimping.
…Paul is expecting the bakers
to form a neat seal.
[Saku] Maybe not that.
It's always that.
I've got a little tool in my pocket.
Aye-aye.
[Rowan] Think pig in blanket,
that was the vibe.
I'm quietly confident.
As soon as I say I'm confident,
it goes wrong.
So I don't wanna say that.
[Noel] Before crimping his lids in place,
Rowan's adding an extra topping
of smoked streaky bacon
to his Cumberland sausage
and sweet potato filling.
-[Paul] Have you got a hole in the lid?
-[Rowan] No.
When it steams, where's it gonna go?
On the bacon, the bacon's raw inside,
so that steam is there to help poach…
-Okay. Got you.
-[Prue] Good luck.
-[Rowan] Thank you.
-Good luck, mate.
You think that's a clue,
maybe put a hole in it?
-You think?
-I feel like that's a clue.
-I might do pricks around it.
-Get a little prick in there.
-I will. Thanks.
-[Alison] Sorted.
[Noel] Once suitably ventilated…
I'm egg washing the top
to give it a lovely colour.
…applying an egg wash
should brown up the pies when baked.
[Cristy] Is it thick?
-Are you asking me?
-Yeah.
Whatever, in.
Oh, I didn't do egg wash.
Okay, bakers,
you've got half an hour left.
[Nicky] This is speed pie making.
Come on, Nicky.
Oven's not on.
[Tasha] Not conventional.
-[Noel] Should've gone in ages ago.
-No, what you saying?
-[both laugh]
-I didn't realise you were the baker.
[Noel] How dare you?
Oh, that's hot.
Do you think that's too hot?
[Dana] Possibly,
but I don't have time.
They're in.
-[Noel] How are you?
-[Nicky] I'm all right-ish.
-Why, what's happened?
-Oh, time.
-Time.
I can be up two hours before we've gotta
be anywhere and I'm still never ready.
-[Alison] What you talking about?
-What time we get up.
-What time do you get up?
-I go to bed quite late.
Get up early. It's weird.
I texted you last night at 11:00.
You texted back, so you were late.
That's right, we're texting
each other at night. [laughs]
Stop sending me them pictures.
I don't like it.
-[laughs]
-That's not what you said last night.
[Alison] While some bakers
have time to wait and watch…
[Tasha] Cranberry sauce.
[Alison] …others are making
their condiments.
[Josh] I'll pipe it on at the end.
I call them post-match picnic pies,
the flavours I do for my rugby lads
after either a training session
or a match day.
Hopefully, in hot water crust pastry,
they taste as good in those as well.
[Alison] Josh is hoping the pickle will
bring moisture to his pork and apple pies
while a layer of cheddar
will be melted on top
when the pies are removed from their tins
and returned to the oven to brown.
The pastry is done now,
so it won't collapse.
Bakers, you've got ten minutes left.
I'm gonna have to get these out now.
-[Rowan] They're oozing.
-[Alison] Did you put the hole in?
I did. Three.
-Oh. And they've opened up?
-Three pricks. Yeah.
Oh, so overfilled.
I don't like the look of 'em.
There's a whole mushroom
coming out here. [sniffles]
Look at these.
[Noel] You're using some
special finger protectors.
-That is it.
-To poke the pies out the bottom.
I've got a picture of Paul
wearing nothing but those.
On his fingers.
-[laughing] Yeah on his…
-Okay. [laughs]
Just glaze them up.
Get all round the sides
as crispy as possible now.
Oh, they look bad, Noel.
-They look good.
-No, they're overfilled.
I don't know why I'm getting like this.
[sniffles] I told myself I don't care.
-[Noel] But you really do care.
-I need to get a life.
[laughs]
[Saku] It's coming out now.
[Rowan] Oh, no.
[gasps]
It's a bit soggy on the bottom.
Never been soggy before.
Bakers, you only have one minute left.
They've gotta come out, haven't they?
[Dana] That one looks peng.
[Dan] Not as crispy as I'd like them.
[Josh] Pleased with those.
[Rowan] It was going so well.
They're not great. Gutted.
Oh, I can't wait
for his beady eyes to look at these.
Bakers, that is your time up,
please step away from your bakes.
[exhales heavily]
[Rowan] One of 'em has no bottom,
they're stuck in the tin.
-Do they normally stick in the tin?
-Never.
-Oh, God.
-So, I'm really upset actually.
[Noel] The bakers'
hot water crust picnic pies
will now be judged by Prue and Paul.
-Hello, Matty.
-Hiya.
-Tell us all about your picnic pies.
They are based on spanakopita.
-Okay.
-[Matty] Based on them.
[Paul] Bit messy.
It's very tricky to get that lattice
looking good on such a small pie.
So, there's some feta, ricotta, spinach,
roasted red peppers
and some sundried tomatoes.
Good strong flavours. Lovely.
[Paul] I think your lid
is a bit too thick.
-Okay.
-[Paul] That takes up
-a third of it.
-[Prue] Yeah.
-Thank you.
-Thanks.
-Cheers.
-Well done.
Beautiful golden brown colour.
So we've got sausage meat,
bacon and cranberry with apple
and some cranberry sauce on the side.
[Prue] Good pastry.
Your mustard bottom,
which I'd never have thought of,
and I think it's a little mark of genius.
It's beautiful.
I think it's filled beautifully,
it's nice and thin round the outside.
-Thank you.
-Cheers.
The pastry's a little pale on top.
Could have been browner.
-[Paul] Bit of a soggy bottom.
-Really?
[Paul] Yeah.
Heartbreaking.
Inside, it's tuna, potatoes,
leeks, carrot and onion,
and there is a quail egg as well.
I love the flavours.
Actually, the filling inside
is quite nice and moist.
[Paul] The pastry needs
to be much thinner.
And less soggy.
You can see right down the bottom
how wet that is there.
It's a bit ripped
and all over the place at the sides.
Your flavours are beautiful.
You pastry is nice and flaky.
Nice and thin round the outside,
well-filled.
-It's just a bit dry on the mouth.
-Okay.
I love the flavour, but it'll be
hard work to eat that whole pie
-because it's very dense.
-Okay.
[Prue] I think they look
really appetising.
If they were in a shop window,
I'd buy them.
This is potato dauphinoise
with caramelised onions and Comté cheese.
[Paul] Your sides are a little thick
on one side, thin on another.
Your roof is a little bit too thick.
-Yeah.
-I like the flavour. Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
My, erm, pies…
[all laugh]
I'm sorry, but…
No, it's, erm… That's good.
Er, my pies are, kind of,
Christmas stuffing pies
with chestnut, cranberry sauce,
sweet potato,
bit of bacon and a loose top.
-[Prue] Lovely pastry.
-Thank you.
It's got such a beautiful aroma
as well as flavour.
[Prue] If it had looked a bit better,
-you'd have had an absolute triumph.
-[Paul] Hmm.
It's bled quite a bit.
That's the bleeding from the interior.
I think they're quite sweet.
So that's sausage meat in there
with some strong cheddar cheese,
erm, tiny bit of apple on top.
That's the problem with sausage mix.
It'll all shrink
and you get gaps around the edge.
You could've put a jelly in there.
Okay.
-Otherwise, your flavours are good.
-Thank you.
[Prue] A little pale,
but I love the shape.
The mould has worked nicely,
got a good colour underneath,
not on the side.
Your pastry's a bit thick.
And you end up
with a big hole in it as well.
-Yeah, a little undercooked too.
-It is.
So what you've got is quite a gloopy
mixture with your pastry being too thick,
and it's a difficult thing to eat.
-It's a disaster.
-[Prue] It's…
-It's not your best.
-[Nicky] No.
-A bit gluey.
-[Nicky] Yeah.
-[Paul] Thank you very much, Nicky.
-Thank you.
-Don't worry about those people.
-It's all right.
-Not bakers, those people.
-[both chuckle]
[Prue] They look even.
They're nice and brown.
They're really tiny, but elegant.
I've made creamy leek mushroom pies.
You know, you're so clever.
You made a creamy sauce, and it just
holds the whole thing together.
Oh, thank you.
It's beautifully moist inside and crispy.
[Prue] Mmm.
So what I will do…
-[gasps] You're joking.
-[applause]
-Well done.
-[Prue] Well done.
It's because you managed
to achieve the moistness and the flavour
in a small area
and have that lattice top looking so nice.
-I feel like I'm in a dream, thank you.
-Well done.
[gasps] Oh, my God.
It's so easy to feel
impostor syndrome of like,
"I'm not good enough" and stuff,
then Paul goes and gives you
a handshake, and you're just like,
"What?" [laughs]
[Rowan] I'm so happy
they like how it tasted
because, you know, looks is one thing.
What's inside is what matters.
[Saku] Oh, dear.
Soggy bottom.
Why it happened to me today?
Absolute bag of pants.
I've just gotta scoop myself off the floor
and get on with it.
[buzzing]
[Alison] For the next challenge,
the ingredients and recipe
are a gingham-guarded secret.
Hello, bakers, welcome back to the tent.
It's time for your technical challenge.
This week it's been set for you
by P. Hollywood, the pastry king.
Now as always, this challenge is judged
blind so our judges will be leaving.
But before you go, have you got
any words of advice for our bakers?
I'm thinking Mel Gibson in Braveheart.
Go for it, Paul.
The textures on the inside
and the outside must be perfect.
Not as stirring as I thought,
if I'm honest.
-He should've done it on a horse.
-[Alison] Maybe.
[Alison and Noel laugh]
Okay, judges, you can go. Thank you.
Paul would like you to make
a decadent dauphinoise pithivier.
[Noel] Now, the judges will be looking
for a buttery, crisp rough puff pastry
encasing creamy potato
and caramelised onion.
And alongside that, a blue cheese sauce.
You have two hours and 45 minutes.
[Alison] On your marks…
-Get set…
-Bake!
Oh, goodness gracious. What is this?
[Dana] What were the chances
that was gonna happen?
I know what dauphinoise is.
What's the other word?
[Rowan] Pithivi…
Pervivi… pervivi… How do you say it?
So, Paul, pithivier?
It's a classic sort of French pie.
Now this particular one's got
the dauphinoise potatoes inside.
What we're really testing the bakers on
is the pastry itself.
By now, our bakers should know
about rough puff pastry.
Yeah, the key thing
when you're making a rough puff
is to add some frozen butter
in between each turn.
Dough, butter, dough, butter,
creates these flaky layers.
That's a bit of a feast, isn't it?
[Paul] Help yourself to the sauce.
Roquefort's such a salty blue cheese,
adds a lot of flavour.
It's really heaven.
This is carbs on carbs served with cream.
Can't wait to get back in the tent
-and have nine versions of this.
-[laughs]
It says, "Make the rough puff pastry."
I'm going to add some water,
try and get a dough.
It's just to bind the dough together,
and then I can wrap it up and chill it.
-[Alison] You've done one of these before?
-Erm, no.
-Oh.
-But I've made dauphinoise.
And I've made rough puff.
So we're sort of there.
There you go. Yeah.
Put it together. What do you got?
-Er--
-Dauphinoise. Pithivier.
[both laughing]
I'm just gonna get it
rolled out to a rough rectangle.
I can put my grated butter in between.
[Dan] So, I'm gonna grate
the, er, frozen butter onto that,
so the butter gives you that puffy rise.
[Noel] But a few of the bakers…
I'm just kind of incorporating
the grated butter.
…are taking a different approach.
Rub the butter in the flour, knead it.
Roll it out.
If they wanted me to laminate it,
put it out as a slab of butter,
so if it's grated,
maybe that should be mixed in.
Now I'm gonna start to fold.
I'm nervous.
So, it's fold third down, third up,
turn, roll, chill.
[Nicky] When you look around
and see what everybody else is doing,
and you think, "Oh, have I done the same?"
It's a bit unnerving, isn't it?
I've grated all of my butter in at once.
Everyone else is laminating it in.
I think I've worked
the butter in too much.
-[Noel] Washed your hand?
-I didn't want to.
-Did he lift you off the ground slightly?
-[laughs] No.
What was it like?
Grabbing a big bunch of sausages?
[laughs] Stop.
I feel like the rule here is cold.
'Cause puff pastry does not like heat.
As soon as it gets too warm, then it
all melts and you won't get the layers.
Starting with the filling
which is simmer the potatoes
in cream, milk, garlic and seasoning.
[Rowan] I've never made
dauphinoise potatoes in my life.
I know someone who has… Dana.
-[Alison] Babes.
-More pressure now.
I love that you made it
and didn't know what it was.
I know. [laughs]
You want it just to,
sort of simmer away nicely.
Checking for tenderness.
I'm a tender little thing.
Simmering away. Onions are caramelising.
I'm worried about the pastry.
[Dana] This is the second turn.
So I'm doing two turns,
which I think will be enough.
Just doing another turn.
Try and get as many as I can in the time.
More folds.
[Josh] I'll give that five minutes.
[Dan groans]
Need another plaster.
Just grated my knuckles.
I got blood in my pastry.
So I've had to redo it.
Need to get a shimmy on now
and chuck it all in and go for it.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
♪ Halfway through ♪
-♪ Halfway through this nightmare ♪
-♪ Ha, ha, ha ♪
I'm just getting these potatoes out.
Spot on, that.
[Dana] Still got bite to it.
[Rowan] I overcooked
my potatoes in the middle,
'cause I've just tried them,
they're a bit soft. So annoying.
[Dan] So I've finally made my pastry.
Done one turn.
I'll do that again,
start assembling, try and get it baked.
[Alison] While Dan performs a final turn,
everyone else is starting
to shape their pithivier.
I have no idea how thick to get it,
to be honest.
Who do you fear in this tent?
Do you fear Saku?
-Yeah.
-I fear Saku.
I wouldn't like to get on her wrong side.
Shall we have a rolling pin fight?
-Saku.
-Yeah?
Dan said do you wanna have
a rolling pin fight?
-Ooh!
-You're a Jedi, Saku.
-Yeah.
-[both laugh]
"Cut a 20-centimetre round
using the smaller plate."
"Layer the potatoes, onions
with salt and pepper and nutmeg
in between each layer."
[Rowan] I've chucked mine on and now
I've seen people do it proper neat.
I'm looking at Cristy's,
it actually looks like
a French person has trained
for 70 years at Le Cordon Bleu.
And then produced that.
Right, so let's move very, very quickly.
I'm just panicking a bit now.
-[Noel] What you putting in there?
-Nutmeg.
When I was a kid, there was a rumour
that if you smoked nutmeg, you'd go crazy.
[laughs]
-Did you try?
-No.
-Oh.
-Sounded ridiculous to me.
[both laughing]
I'm gonna overload it with all the onions.
The onions give it a nice sweetness.
It says, "Scallop the edges."
I ain't got a clue what that means.
[Cristy] Is this scalloping?
-'Cause I just know it as crimping.
-Scalloping.
Crimping, scalloping,
it's all the same to me.
"Knock up the edges,
then glaze and chill."
What is this "knock up" thing?
Different connotations to "knock up,"
isn't there? [chuckles]
Ah. Like that?
[Rowan] Well, this is the dirtiest
knock up I've ever seen.
I'm just gonna score it now.
Carefully, not going through the pastry.
And then bake it.
We're going in.
[Josh] Don't know how it's gonna take.
[Nicky] How long have we got?
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
[Dan] I'd better get a move on.
It's going quick, isn't it?
So, in the meantime,
I can make my blue cheese sauce.
Just smelled that cheese,
and it is absolutely revolting. [laughs]
-[Saku] It's pungent.
-[Matty] I don't like blue cheese.
You got to try it though,
-'cause it's got to taste good.
-No.
-Look how mouldy it is.
-Look at this.
-So mouldy, there's nearly no cheese.
-I know.
It's Roquefort, isn't it?
I love Roquefort.
Super cheesy, baby.
Well done, Dan, yours is rising.
-Nice colour.
-[Dan] Looks all right.
It looks pale,
so I've upped the temp by ten degrees.
[softly] Scared.
Bakers, you've got five minutes.
[Cristy] Didn't use all my potatoes.
Look at it, it's flat like a pancake.
Oh, he's gonna hate it.
Oh, it's so bad.
It's not risen, has it?
It's like a frisbee. So gutted.
I've just had a crap day.
-Hello, Josh. You all right?
-Erm, okay.
-[Noel] You worried it won't puff?
-[Josh] Yeah.
Want me to burn the tent down
so that he won't see?
-That'd be good.
-[Noel laughs]
I want to give it
as long as humanly possible.
[Nicky] I might take it out.
Cornish pasty, anyone?
If you like shortcrust pastry,
it's all right. [laughs]
Bakers, you have one minute left.
She's gonna have to come out.
[Josh] Gonna have a gander.
It's not as puffy as it should be.
I'm happy with that.
[Cristy] Look at it, it's so ugly.
I've seen neater poos,
to be honest with you.
[Dan] I quite like the look of that.
[Tasha] I don't think that's done.
God, this is revolting. [sighs]
Bakers, that is your time up.
Well done.
[Dan] Tough, that.
Please bring your pithiviers,
place on the table behind your photos.
Look at the size of Dan's.
It's like he's got a body
in there. [laughs]
Don't, yours is right next
to the frisbee. [chuckles]
[Noel] Prue and Paul are looking for
a perfectly-domed dauphinoise pithivier
with a flaky laminated rough puff pastry.
[Paul] Eclectic mix.
Yeah. Some are domed, some are not.
Yes.
[Alison] And they have no idea
whose is whose.
-[Paul] We'll start with this one.
-[Prue] A recognisable pithivier.
[Paul] Yes. It's got a dome,
design is pretty good.
-[Prue] And a nice colour.
-[Paul] Nice and crispy. Yeah.
It's certainly got a bit of flake.
Mmm. The Roquefort's certainly salty.
-And it does make the balance beautiful.
-Yeah.
[Paul] Now, moving on to this flat pizza.
[Prue] This is definitely
not domed enough.
[Paul] Needs to be much higher.
It's a bit pale, though.
[Prue] Yeah. Bit uneven too.
[Paul] Needed a stronger colour.
I like the colour.
-Nice and strong, golden brown.
-[Prue] Yeah.
Do you know, this pastry is delicious,
-but it's not quite cooked.
-[Paul] No, it's not.
It needed a little bit longer, didn't it?
-Love the scallop work on this.
-And it's got a dome.
[Paul] Looks good underneath.
Good, strong colour.
Mmm. Pastry's not bad actually.
It's flaky enough. It's a nice one, that.
Okay moving on, this is a bit flat.
[Prue] Bit underbaked, I think.
[Paul] Lamination looks
more bread-like than flaky.
I think the potatoes are a bit raw too.
Mmm, potatoes need a little bit longer.
There's an attempt to get a bit of height.
-I'm not mad about the look of it.
-It's a bit rough.
-Yeah.
-Hmm. Tater's raw.
Yeah, needs longer. The flake's not bad.
[Prue] This one, Paul,
has a lovely colour.
Bit of height to it as well.
-Nice, strong bake.
-[Prue] Raw potato.
[Paul] Mmm. It is. It's quite raw.
[Prue] This looks like an interesting pie,
but it's not a pithivier.
[Paul] No. Not a dome in sight.
There's a bit of flake to that.
-[Prue] Pastry's good.
-It needed more of a dome.
Not sure what happened
to the rest of the potatoes.
It seems to be a bit uneven on this one.
Not really neat.
It's got a flake to it.
Mmm. Spuds are all right.
Sauce is very tarragon-y, I love it.
It's blended with the blue cheese,
it works beautifully.
[Noel] The pithiviers will now be
ranked from last to first.
Okay. In ninth spot, we have this one.
Whose is this? Nicky?
It's too flat,
there is no crumble in there.
In eighth place, we have this one.
-Josh. Too pale, too flat.
-[softly] Okay.
[Alison] Matty is seventh, Saku sixth,
Cristy fifth,
Rowan fourth,
and Tasha is third.
In second place,
we have this one.
Dana, it looks very pretty,
the pastry's good, tastes good,
it's a really good pithivier.
-Thank you.
-[Prue] Well done.
So in first place, we have this one. Dan.
[Prue] Well done.
A lovely pithivier.
I love the scallop work,
you've ended up with something
that tastes delicious
and looks professional.
-Well done.
-Thanks.
-[Saku] Well done.
Great feeling. Good. Can't believe it.
Every time it happens, I'm like,
"I can't believe it."
First time I've been second.
I'm beyond happy, I'm over the moon.
I'll try and take positives out of today,
and just hope I have a good day tomorrow.
-[Nicky laughs]
-Oh, babe, come here. Oh.
[Nicky laughs] Oh, dearie me.
I'll have to do an awful lot
to pull it back from today.
[buzzing]
[Nicky] Loosens you up.
[Alison] I don't think I've ever seen
you both eat as much
as I've seen in Pastry Week.
Come to my house, every day is the same.
Overall, Pastry Week's
been a step up from Chocolate Week.
And Cristy got a handshake.
They were great pies.
For Star Baker, I think she's in line.
Dan won the technical.
-[Prue] Tasha's back with a bang.
-[Paul] Tasha's come back.
-We're sending two people home this week.
-[Noel] Yes.
I was thinking that.
So who roughly is in danger?
-Nicky.
-Yeah.
[Prue] She is so cheerful.
But she is not doing well.
[Paul] Saku's in trouble.
-Is she?
-Struggled in the sig, 6th in technical.
-I love Saku.
-Saku can't go.
[Paul] Rowan could drop down.
Those picnic pies were awful.
What I think's disappointing, is Josh.
I can't believe Josh would be in danger.
He's been consistent.
But not this week.
[Alison] I love all of them.
I want 'em all to do well.
-[Noel] They're becoming a tight gang.
-[Paul] They are.
-They've got a WhatsApp group.
-Have they?
[Alison] Yeah.
When are we
gonna have a WhatsApp group?
-Are we gonna do that?
-We have one without you.
[both laugh]
Welcome back to the tent
for your showstopper challenge.
Today, the judges would love you
to make something out of pastry.
Who would've thought it?
How do they come up with this stuff? Wild.
The judges would like you to make
a stunning display
of decorative sweet pies.
Your display should include
at least three ornate pies
and be made of a rich sweet pastry case.
You have four hours.
-[Alison] On your marks…
-Get set…
-[in Jamaican accent] Bake!
-[Prue laughing]
[Tasha] They tasted great in practice,
but practice took six hours.
[Saku] I am starting with
making the sweet shortcrust pastry.
[Prue] We're asking the bakers
to produce at least three
highly-decorated pies
made with a rich sweet pastry.
I'm just using the traditional
"rub it in" method.
[Prue] Ideally, I think it would be nice
if at least two of them
had different fillings.
[Cristy] I'm starting
with my raspberry jam.
That's the food I grew up on.
We want it highly-decorated,
so we're expecting a bit of latticework,
plaiting on the top.
I think it's perfectly legitimate to dye
some of the pastry.
We wanna see something
that links the pies together.
I'm making sweet pies based
on my favourite British sitcom,
Absolutely Fabulous.
[Paul] You can't leave a sweet pie
in the mould or the foil,
they need to bring it out, expose it
and show us what they've baked.
[Nicky] I've got cramp in my hands.
[laughing] It's really sore.
[Paul] It needs to taste amazing…
This is a vanilla pastry.
…hold together
and create that beautiful crumble
when you bite into it
with whatever sweet filling is inside.
[Dana] I've got the vision,
it's whether I can execute it well.
What have I done to this?
-[Paul] Hi, Cristy.
-Hello.
Right, Cristy, tell us all
about your decorative pies.
So, I'm gonna try and do,
like, a woodland sort of display of pies.
I'm gonna do a spiced apple pie,
and then I've got a blueberry pie,
and then a raspberry and frangipane pie.
-Lovely, I love all of those flavours.
-Okay, good.
[Alison] After
a handshake-worthy signature,
Cristy will be hoping her autumnal
showstopper featuring raspberry frangipane
and intricate latticework
will earn her top honours again today.
When you practised, did you time it?
Yeah. It's hard to practise
for four hours around the children,
so I've been doing really late nights.
-Middle of the night.
-Middle of… Yeah, literally.
Hope I deliver.
[Noel] Cristy's not the only baker
who found practice a little fraught.
[Rowan] In practice,
the bottom fell out of my pie.
So it was just a crust around the edge
and then a dropped pie.
Which is why I've got parchment.
It might not be crisp,
but I'd rather have a not crisp edge
than a no edge at all.
[Alison] Rowan's pâte sablée pies
will be filled with lemon and blueberry
and frangipane
with flaked almonds and chocolate.
Patsy and Eddy
will appear in pastry relief silhouette
leaving Rowan
to paint their faces by hand.
[Alison] Oh, it's Patsy.
What about timing? Got a plan?
Erm, no.
The thing about you is,
you go with the flow.
Yeah. It might look rubbish,
but it tastes great.
-But this doesn't. I'm quite impressed.
-I'm surprised.
[Noel] Rowan's not alone
in celebrating the matriarchy.
[Josh] Nan's always pushing me
to enter the Bake Off.
I said I would,
and after she was ill and passed away,
I wasn't ready, so I waited another year.
[Noel] Josh's showstopper
is for his late grandmother, Frieda.
[Josh] I used to do
quite a bit of baking at her house.
Used to go out from Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday after school.
I did this
from the age of about five or six.
I was still doing it
when I was doing my PhD.
That's why I know a lot
about all the flowers around here
because, erm,
she taught me all about flowers.
[Alison] Josh is making a sunflower
with two pineapple and apricot flowerheads
and three apple, blackberry
and coconut leaves
all complete
with coloured pastry and syrup glaze.
-You seem calm about this challenge.
-I am.
You weren't very happy yesterday.
Are you calmer now doing this?
I would've liked to have done better
on the technical.
You got high standards for yourself.
I put too much pressure on myself.
Hopefully this is all right today.
-Look forward to it.
-[Prue] Sounds good.
[Josh] That's my floral. Done.
[Alison] Josh's grandmother
isn't the only one
to get the showstopper treatment.
[Nicky] They're all flavours
from my gran's garden
'cause she had apple trees,
she had a plum tree,
there was always rhubarb.
Her baking
was like a pair of comfy old slippers.
[Noel] Nicky's comforting pies
will be filled with apple and pear,
plum and frangipane, and rhubarb
and custard with a smidge of ginger,
while colourful latticework and flowers
should prove a feast for the eyes.
[Paul] I know you didn't
have a decent day yesterday,
but today is your day, Nicky.
And you seem very calm,
so it all looks good.
-Calm on the surface.
-[Prue laughs]
You should see what's going on under here.
-[Paul] Little duck legs going?
-You can do it.
[Dana] I'm just gonna toast the nuts.
I am doing a honey baklava pie.
-[gasps]
-It's got pistachios and hazelnuts
and walnuts in an orange syrup
on the bottom base
with an almond frangipane on top.
-Yeah.
-Oh, you had me at marzipan.
-I didn't say marzipan. [chuckles]
-[laughing]
-Almonds, close enough.
-You had me at almonds.
[Noel] Her frangipane and baklava main pie
will be paired with mulled wine
and apple miniature pies
and decorated
with a sturdy shortcrust tree.
I like a good chunky pastry.
So, that's what I'm hoping for,
but we shall see if that works.
[Alison] When the bakers
are happy with their pastry…
It looks like it's rested well.
…it's time to roll.
Tell you what,
this jumper will be coming off soon.
About two or three millimetres
is what I'm looking for.
[Noel] Before lining the pie tins
to a standard expected by the judges…
[gasps]
Hello. [chuckles]
Press it in.
You've just made a hole. [laughs]
Ten minutes in the freezer,
firms it up, then we can blind bake.
I'm making a pineapple,
cherry and rum pie, and apple pie.
Apple from Herefordshire, where I live.
And pineapple
from my birth country, Sri Lanka.
Representing bit of both worlds.
[Alison] Intelligence analyst Saku
is making
an infographic-inspired pie display
built from a sweet shortcrust pastry
made by replacing
some of the butter with cream cheese.
-I've never made pastry with cream cheese.
-Cream cheese.
Very interesting.
It tastes better.
Is it quite a flaky pastry?
It is melt-in-the-mouth kind of pastry.
Oh, okay.
I look forward to this one, Saku.
I'll get my pastry in
'cause I need to get blind baking.
It's gonna go in for ten minutes,
so it's partially baked for the filling.
I'm not blind baking. Everybody else is.
It's going in, come on.
Ooh, actually it's not going in.
It needs to go on a tray.
Silly sausage that I am.
[Dan] You will fit in there, you will fit,
you won't fit in there.
How long do we have?
I am the genie of the kettle.
You have three wishes, my child.
Amazing, first wish,
can you do the time call?
-I'm a little bit busy.
-No problem.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
That's ages, that is.
I'm ready to start
getting all the decoration ready.
[Noel] Prue and Paul are expecting
that decoration to be highly detailed.
[Nicky] I'm just doing the leaves.
[Noel] But while the bakers prepare these…
I'm making my chocolate genoise sponge.
…and their other fillings…
For my frangipane, I've whizzed
some raspberries through there.
…they need to keep a watchful eye
on their blind-baked pastry.
Looking good. Hopefully.
We'll see when I lift these off.
[Cristy] My pastry
just doesn't look right.
I can't do nothing now. Okay.
I need it partially baked,
it'll go back in with all the fillings.
I don't wanna get it too golden and burnt.
[Alison] Baked too long and the pastry
might become too dry and crumbly
to attach the decorative lid to later on.
-Dan, what an absolute mess.
-[Dan] I'm sorry.
[Alison] What's going on,
what's the matter?
[Dan] It's a good sign.
It means that my pastry
is extremely crumbly and yummy.
[Alison] Inspired by his travels
in South America,
Dan's making a pie
for his favourite destinations.
Cherry for Peru, grape for Argentina,
and tropical fruits for Brazil.
[Dan] I've started my decorations.
[Alison] How many elements have you got?
[Dan] About 14,600 at the moment.
It's really intricate.
It's still a bit of a mess,
-but it'll be fine.
-I'll hoover up when I'm done.
[Noel] And Dan is not the only baker
taking the judges on their travels.
[Tasha] The theme is, like,
my two favourite places,
'cause I like skiing and I also like…
I just like the… the sea.
Erm, so the central pie is like a signpost
going to those two places.
[Noel] Tasha's sea pie will contain
a filling of apricot and ricotta.
The mountains chestnut and blueberries,
while her pecan pie signpost
will spell out her favourite places
in British Sign Language.
[Tasha] It's almost like a teaching moment
for a little bit of fingerspelling.
It's really difficult
to do in pastry. [laughs]
It's a bit thinner than I wanted.
I made a mistake, but it's okay.
[Alison] And Matty is also heading
to the slopes.
[Matty] I've been Andorra, Sestriere,
and Léger in France.
I love it there, it's quality.
[Alison] Matty's pies will make the ideal
après-ski comfort food,
filled with rhubarb and custard,
apple and cinnamon, and plums.
How are you using
your plums in the, er, pie?
So, I'm gonna stew these down slightly.
[Noel laughs] Stew down your plums.
[Matty] Indeed.
[Prue] Yeah.
With the stem ginger,
some of the orange juice as well.
-I love ginger and plums. It works.
-[Noel laughs]
[sighs]
-Stop it, boys.
-Sorry, Prue.
Enough.
[Noel] With pastry cases prepared…
[Rowan] This is the lemon
and blueberry, kind of, curd.
[Noel] …it's time to assemble.
Today is two years to the day
since she passed away.
I hope I do these flavours justice.
[Saku] It's fine isn't it? Yeah.
Come on, Nick. Stick everything else on.
I just want to get this one in ASAP Rocky.
I'm gonna try and move
like no one's business.
[Noel] What you doing, egg wash?
-Yeah, a bit more.
-I used to egg wash my legs.
-[Cristy] Did ya?
-Yeah. They come up nice.
-Quite glossy.
-You have great skin, though.
-We always talk about it.
-Like a dolphin.
[Josh] They will go in for
about 30 minutes, I think.
Everything's in the oven.
Just see what happens.
I'm feeling so confident,
watch it all crumble at the last second.
[Dan] How long's left?
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
[Dan] You're joking. Running out of time.
[Dana] Dan, you okay?
-Running late like usual.
-[Dana] Don't worry.
Cheerio!
I've got one flan in, I am elated.
-Let me tell you.
-[beeping]
[Dana] There's a lot of spillage.
[laughs] There's a bit
of a plumbing issue happening.
[Alison] Dana's not the only one
who's sprung a leak.
I'm having a spillage. The top's kind of
separated from the bottom on that one.
It's severe, and getting more severe
every time I look at it.
A spillage in the village.
Come on, you can do this, Nick.
Crank it up again, 200.
[Rowan] Look at it.
How the hell is that gonna come out?
I've just put the BSL fingerspelling on,
so it's going back in the oven.
I'm just hoping
it doesn't melt completely.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
Come on, you can do this.
Just shove that in as it is.
[Noel] As Nicky gets her final pie
in the oven,
the other bakers
are beginning to take theirs out.
I'm happy with that.
That's a nice golden brown colour.
Where have the mountains gone?
This is genuinely traumatising.
I need another pair of hands.
It's a bit stuck.
[Saku] No soggy bottom.
-Yes.
-[Alison] What do we need to do?
Could you grab these two ends,
and I grab this and lift.
-It just cracked.
-[Alison] What?
It just broke.
-It hasn't.
-It snapped.
We'll try one more time,
we'll see what happens. Really carefully.
Three, two, one. That's gone.
Yeah, no, that's split.
Oh, no, what do I do?
-Serve it in the tin. Nothing else to do.
-Shall I?
If they say anything, just say
that Noel said, "Serve it in the tin."
[both laugh]
[Rowan] This is not happening today.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
[Saku] Ah! Disaster.
[Dan] Wow, got a bit of a leak.
Ooh.
[Rowan] Why has this never happened?
Bakers, that is your time up.
Flipping heck.
Please step away
from your pastry showstoppers.
Do you know what, guys?
I've tried my best.
[Rowan] This is terrible.
-[Nicky] Want a hug?
-[Rowan sighs]
A very sweaty hug.
[Nicky laughs]
[Rowan] Oh, Nicky.
[Alison] The bakers'
sweet decorative pie showstoppers
will now be judged by Paul and Prue.
It's a sensational display,
and I love the way you've decorated them.
Yeah.
Let's try the bottom one first.
-This is apple, cinnamon…
-And, erm, sultanas.
[Paul] That's held together.
The flavour of that's spot on.
-[sighs] Okay.
-[Paul] It's beautifully cooked. Soft.
-This is the…
-[Cristy] Raspberry and frangipane.
I've never had frangipane
with raspberry in it before.
-That's amazing. I love that.
-[chuckles softly]
-This is blueberry.
-[Cristy] Yeah.
I like the blueberry.
It's intense, very American.
I think there are three very good pies.
-Okay, great.
-Well done.
[Paul] Thank you.
I would be tempted
to put a glaze on this, you know.
Just looks a bit rough and ready.
Especially this one.
This is the pecan pie.
There's a bit of whisky in there,
so a bit like an American pecan pie.
I really like that.
-It's beautifully crispy.
-[Prue] Mmm.
The mountain pie has a blueberry
sweet pastry with a chestnut layer.
-[Prue] Goodness.
-[Paul] Wow, that's vibrant.
It's quite wet inside.
The pastry is like cake.
-[Paul] Hmm.
-Okay.
The sunburst pie is an apricot
and ricotta pie with a sweet pastry.
-It's a lovely texture. Tastes delicious.
-[Paul] Hmm.
-I love the tartness from the apricot.
-Thank you.
[Dan] The bottom pie
is a cherry and kirsch
with a chocolate sweet shortcrust.
[Prue] I like the compote inside there.
But I don't think
the chocolate crust works with it.
It's a bit sandy and dry.
-[Paul] Next one.
-[Dan] A grape and strawberry.
But grapes on their own
are very subtle in flavour, so it's lost.
[Dan] And the top pie
is mango, papaya and pineapple
with a lemon and lime sweet shortcrust.
[Paul] The textures on the base
are lovely.
I'm not sure of the textures of the fruit
'cause they're not right.
-Needed more cooking.
-Not hitting my heights.
So this is my tree.
You've got a baklava pie, so we've got
pistachios, hazelnuts and walnuts
mixed with an orange syrup
and there's a frangipane filling on top.
That is delicious, but it's very rich.
-It's very sweet.
-Mmm-hmm.
The frangipane's too thick.
Means, now it's underbaked.
[Prue] What is this one?
[Dana] This is my mulled wine apple pie.
It's got some blackcurrants
running through it.
-Too sour?
-[Prue] Mmm-hmm.
[Paul] Hits you right there.
-I think it is perhaps too powerful.
-Mmm-hmm.
-They're a bit, erm--
-[Prue] Broken.
[Paul] A little bit rustic.
[Matty] Apple and blackberry
with some cinnamon.
Some of the top is actually raw.
-Okay.
-Flavour's not bad.
-Rhubarb and custard.
-[Matty] Yeah.
The rhubarb comes through well there.
That's a very good pie.
-[Paul] Reticent to try this one.
-[Prue] It's collapsed.
-Plum and some ginger.
-The fruit is undercooked.
The best one is the rhubarb and custard
by quite a margin. Thank you.
[Prue] Saku, what I really love about this
is it looks so simple and fresh.
The big pie is pineapple, cherry and rum.
Erm, the fruit's quite raw.
I wouldn't go back
for a second piece.
-Let's have a look at the apple and…
-Apple and cinnamon.
I really like the apple.
Cinnamon level's just about right.
-Pastry's nice, delicate and buttery.
-I think that's delicious. Well done.
Thank you very much.
[Prue] That is a work of art.
You've got a very simple theme,
but it pulls all the pies together
most excellently.
[Josh] It's a pineapple and apricot pie
spiced with cinnamon stick, star anise
and some vanilla in there.
-That's really good.
-Oh, good.
It's tart, it's sweet, it's crunchy,
it's got depth to it. It's delicious.
-I can't fault that.
-Thank you.
The leaves are made
with a coconut, apple and blackberry pie.
That's delicious.
[Prue] And the right texture.
It holds together, but it's moist.
This is what we've been looking for.
It's wonderful. Well done.
-Well done.
-Yes, Josh!
[Prue] You've got Patsy pretty perfectly.
Eddy's less successful, I think.
Eddy is filled with cherry and vanilla.
I can't really…
[grunts] It's so difficult.
[Rowan chuckles]
This didn't happen at home.
[Paul] It's just pouring out.
Nothing's set.
-The pastry's very good.
-Thank you.
Crisp, very short, but it looks awful.
It's very clumsy.
-You can't get it out of the tin.
-Nope.
Patsy is filled with lemon and blueberry.
Very clumsy, and you say
they were all right at home?
Honestly, lovely, yeah.
This one has got the opposite problem.
[Rowan] This is a chocolate frangipane
and just a standard almond frangipane
with flaked almonds.
[Prue] It's very solid. Too dry.
-Besides that…
-[Prue and Rowan laugh]
-…it's pretty good.
-Success.
[Prue] I think they're all very pretty.
You've made a real effort to jolly it up.
I love that, of course.
The first one
is an apple, pear and hazelnut pie.
-Never had a dry apple pie before.
-[Nicky] Oh… [laughs]
Well, there's a first for everything.
I think, partially,
it's because it's so exposed.
All the moisture that was in that pie
has just evaporated off.
The second one is rhubarb, custard
and a wee bit of ginger in there.
[Prue] Custard's worked really well.
It's pretty thick,
but it's absolutely set.
The pastry's too thick for the filling,
so there's hardly any filling.
-Deeper pie.
-Yeah.
And then the third one
is frangipane and plum.
It's a punchy flavour and it's thin,
so you've got that,
and then the plum top
is about right as well.
-Quite a nice flavour.
-Delicious.
-Yeah.
-Thank you.
Oh, I've got take a positive that it was
sort of really short and nice pastry,
and actually, she did say
that the flavours were good.
[Josh] I was trying to hold it back,
"My goodness, incredible."
Oh, they loved it. I'm so pleased.
If Josh got Star Baker,
I'd be over the moon for him.
But to even be in the mix
for Star Baker's, like, amazing.
[Rowan] Their comments were polite
for what they could've said.
What a disaster. [chuckles]
[buzzing]
[Alison] I am nervous for today.
A double whammy.
-I know. It's painful.
-Who's it gonna be?
We know them all so well now.
I thought Rowan's pies were so awful.
-It looked a little bit like soup.
-We needed a straw.
I was a bit surprised with Dana's efforts.
I think she lost her edge a little bit
in the showstopper.
There's an argument for Saku to be there,
but has she done enough
on her showstopper to save herself?
-And Nicky's down there.
-[Noel] I feel bad for Nicky.
I think she's had
a tough week, hasn't she?
I think Star Baker's
between a couple of people.
I think Cristy, Josh.
I think Josh's sunflower was as perfect
a piece of pastry as you could hope for.
-And Cristy, she's had…
-[Paul and Alison] Yeah.
-…a much better week.
-Yeah.
What happens now?
You eat the rest of the pies?
[Paul] I'm not. If I expand any more,
I'll take someone's eye out
with that button.
[all laughing]
[Noel] Prue and Paul have decided
who'll be this week's Star Baker
and which two bakers
will be leaving the competition.
[Alison] Now I've got the great job
of announcing this week's Star Baker,
and this is someone who the judges thought
was consistent throughout.
So this week's Star Baker is…
-Cristy.
-[cheers and applause]
-[chuckles]
-Well done.
Thank you. [chuckles]
I knew that was coming.
Ah, that means I've got the horrible job
of announcing who's leaving us.
And, as you know,
two people will be going this week.
And the people
that are leaving us this week are…
Nicky and Rowan.
Come here. Come here. [chuckles]
-[Nicky] It's been a blast.
-[Paul] That wasn't your week, was it?
What did I say? It was like a bag of pants
this week, so… [laughs]
-I had a lovely time.
-I'll miss you.
[laughing] You can't stay in
after a bag of pants. There's no way.
Can I have a hug, my love?
Absolutely gutted.
Everybody's just been fab. Saying goodbye
is the worst part about this.
Not the absolute roast I got
at the showstopper.
I promise I can bake. Oh, come here, Paul.
I think Rowan went
because of that showstopper.
Oh, we've had a blast.
[Paul] The other person who's had
a bad week is Nicky.
It's been really sad to let them go.
-[Prue] Well done.
-[Cristy] Thank you so much.
I've got this boost
which I probably needed,
'cause I think sometimes
when you're a mum,
everything's for everyone else.
And you sort of put your dreams on hold.
Star Baker and a handshake.
That's more than most people get.
And it means more than Paul and Prue
maybe even could imagine.
Next week…
[Saku] I'm very pleased
that I can come back.
Having said that,
I need to up my game to survive.
[closing theme music playing]